wir gehen direkt in die ukraine wo
unsere reporter peter hell und paul
ronzheimer in kiew die nacht in einem
bunker verbracht haben dort nach empfang
suchen es ist nicht so einfach jetzt
scheint ihr beiden eine verbindung zu
uns gefunden zu haben peter und paul
schildert uns einmal wir diese nacht
verbracht hat und was euch die menschen
die dort festsitzen und ich wissen was
über ihnen einige meter über ihnen
passiert wie es ihren liebsten geht wie
sie diese nacht verbracht haben was ihr
euch schillern
hahn 4 uhr und 4 uhr gegen erst mal der
erste bombenalarm los im anschluss
dessen kam zweite nation erschütterten
die innenstadt das waren maßstab körper
offenbar die sind einige kilometer von
hier entfernt eigentlich schlagen und um
24 wir waren dann auch im bunker 24 ist
dann ein
russisches flugzeug abgeschossen worden
von der ukrainischen frage und dieses
flugzeug ist an explodierten teile sind
auf ein wohnblock gefallen und eben auf
waren und in diesem wohnblock waren eben
auch menschen sind hier jetzt sitzen und
das hat sein und auch diese dame jetzt
fernsehen guckt und diesel frau das hat
seinen grund weil das sind die
angehörigen des koches der hier als koch
arbeitet und die menschen sind so nach
und nach im amt angekommen und sie
werden jetzt auch die nächte hier
verbringen die nächsten nächte können
mal ganz kurz gucken
wir müssen uns dann heute nacht
irgendwie schauen dass wir uns hier ein
schlafquartier einrichten wir sind nur
sagen
hier ist aus gesehen da haben wir gehört
dass es heftige kämpfe gegeben haben
soll keine 56 kilometer messen
beim weg nach kiel bier her haben wir
ein fighter jet ein kampfflugzeug
gesehen was der sehr flach geflogen ist
man kameramann jorges mehtap ist und ich
haben uns wirklich erschreckt gestanden
gerade auf einer autobahnbrücke als
dieses flugzeug glücklich hatte das
gefühl über unseren köpfen stand und
dann waren wir dort in den straßen
unterwegs auf dem weg nach dir dein auto
und hilft uns an wir dachten zunächst
dass russische truppen tatsächlich waren
es zivile verteidigungs einheiten aus
kehrt also zivilisten die jetzt bereit
sind ihr land zu verteidigen es gibt
auch bilder die gezeigt haben wie heute
waffen verteilt wurden hier also man
bereitet sich auch variiert auch auf
einen häuserkampf vor der blutig werden
kann paul du hältst ja oder versuchst
dass zumindest in diesen stunden weiter
kontakte zu halten zu den beiden
klitschko-brüdern auch also zum
bürgermeister von kiew und seinem bruder
vladimir auch drähte in die ukrainische
regierung rund um den präsidenten
selensky hast du natürlich was ist im
moment den eindruck in welchem zustand
sich die ukrainische regierung befindet
also sind die überhaupt arbeitsfähig
ich habe tatsächlich vor einer stunde
ungefähr mit wladimir klitschko
telefoniert er war zusammen mit vital
lesen waren gerade unterwegs in der
stadt beide immer seite an seite die
brüder so wie man sie aus den boxring
kennt jetzt hier auch in kiew in diesen
schweren stunden und muss noch einmal
sagen dass die situation in wirklich
beängstigend ist insofern als dass die
straßen völlig leer sind normalerweise
eine pulsierende millionenstadt staus
jeden tag geht deshalb jeden nachmittag
und jetzt kaum ein auto dort zu sehen
wladimir klitschko sagte mir als er dort
mit witali war die situation ist sehr
schwierig aber wir kämpfen dass er seine
aussage er berichtete von schweren
kämpfen die dort stattfinden er selbst
war in dem moment in time amt beteiligt
sondern um
organisatorisches auch für die stadt
kehrt aber das haben wir jetzt bereits
mehrfach und hingehört
wenn es so weit kommen sollte will auch
erkämpfen la vitali klitschko jetzt gibt
es erste meldungen dass angeblich der
russische präsident beziehungsweise noch
die russische regierung und der
schirmherr ist bereit wieder sei dass
man versuche irgendwelche gesprächskanal
in die ukrainische regierung wieder zu
öffnen welches vertrauen hast du in
solche meldungen paul denn irgendwie
passt das nicht zusammen der präsident
von der ukraine selenz gesagt er
befindet sich selbst sind in todesangst
mache sich sorgen um sein eigenes leben
die kämpfe rund um auch die
regierungsviertel dort in kiel von
gleichzeitig öffnet man angeblich wieder
einen gesprächskanal mit diesen menschen
in wahrheit ist es so k die ukrainische
armee kann sich zwar verteilten hier
stunden tage aber am ende ist natürlich
die russische armee der ukraine
überlegenswerte lenski überleben will
oder nicht festgenommen werden will wenn
ist noch irgendeine chance geben soll
dann kommt er gar nicht daran vorbei
irgendeiner form zu verhandeln und wir
erinnern uns an die nacht des angriffs
als klar war dass es passieren würde ich
habe mittlerweile mein zeitgefühl
verloren aber es waren 36 stunden
mittlerweile ungefähr da hat sie lenski
in einem fast verzweifelten akt noch
einmal versucht moskau anzurufen und er
hat dann gesagt sind gemäss es ist
niemand ans telefon gegangen also den
ski der ukrainische präsident ist bereit
für verhandlungen das hat er auch immer
wieder gesagt erst vor einer woche war
ich mit ihm im land unterwegs mario pohl
waren wir in donetsk fahren wird und er
hat in diesen gesprächen hat sich zeit
genommen sie haben teilweise noch
gescherzt über das kaputte handy das er
hat denn auch ich habe ein talent mein
handy immer fallen zu lassen was in den
ski offenbar auch passiert also da war
er relativ locker noch aber auch sehr
bestimmt er hat gesagt wir wollen mit
russland sprechen ich will mit ladegerät
sprechen denn es gibt nur eine
möglichkeit ihr eine friedliche lösung
was sagen dir die menschen in diesem
bunker wie positionieren sie sich
zerrissen zwischen der liebe zu ihrem
land und gleichzeitig dem wunsch nach
frieden wie positionieren sie sich da
gerade wollen sie denn wollen sie die
molotow-cocktails basteln zu denen ihr
präsidenten aufgefordert hat oder wollen
sie dass man langsam gespräche sowie
noch einmal hier umgehen
naja die menschen positionieren sich
natürlich insofern als dass sie nach wie
vor einfach gar nicht mehr hören was die
europäische union oder was auf die
deutschen politiker gesagt haben denn
für sie ist das eigentlich schon zu ende
ist ist eigentlich ihr schicksal fügen
dass ihr schicksal eigentlich besiegelt
ist sie warten jetzt nur noch darauf
dass jetzt was jetzt passiert die
nächsten stunden und die politik und das
ganze was im vorfeld stattgefunden hat
die hoffnung auf eine politische und vor
allem eine friedliche lösung wie haben
die menschen hier schon seit zwei tagen
spätestens nach dem angriff der russen
mir auf die ukraine haben die begraben
also hier geht es jetzt nur noch ums
nackte überleben regiert ist uns fliegen
konnte in seiner wohnung ist oder in
einem bunker der versucht ihr zu
überleben und die nächsten tage eben zu
überstehen und dann ist die stunde null
und dann die 1000 schon richtig sagte
man kann widerstand weiß mit den letzten
endes kommt man an dieser supermacht
russland wird man unterlegen sein und
dann wird sich die frage stellen was
kommt danach nach dieser ukraine und
dafür haben die menschen genauso viel
angst wie vor dieser macht jetzt
erklärte uns einmal wir diese zeit in
diesem bunker dort abläuft woher bekommt
man essen woher bekommt man trinken wie
kann man kommunizieren
wir haben wir haben essen haben wir im
moment ganz wenig relativ bibel guck mal
runter hier haben wir wasser noch
oben ist aber noch ein bisschen mehr
essen haben wir hier wie gehen wir durch
es wurde ganz lecker gekocht immer mal
reingucken das ist porsche er ist noch
relativ gut war hat auch lecker
geschmeckt das ist ein spiel weniger
essen wie wir jetzt aber auch in den
letzten zwei tagen bekommen haben weil
alles hat zu es gibt ganz supermarkt
kein restaurant gar nichts hat offen
wann das problem überhaupt was zu essen
hat also gerade hier
die schallplatten käse sind denke habe
ich mir drei reingetan und trockenes
brot aber das ist auch wurscht weil im
moment haben wir wirklich andere sorgen
als essen das tut auch mal ganz gut wenn
mal nichts ist wichtig ist dass wir
wasser haben bestellungen haben die es
alle unter unten dh wir können senden
wir haben drei fall und es gibt auch
eine toilette also wir müssen uns die
arrangieren wir sind jetzt etwa ich weiß
nicht wenn heute abend noch mehr
kollegen reinkommen ich jetzt mal dass
wir 30 40 leute sind dann müssen wir uns
halten und dann müssen wir gucken was
die nacht das mag jetzt im moment
vielleicht noch das gefühl sein hat das
ist jetzt vorübergehend theoretisch
könnte das ja aber sehr sehr lange
dauern dass man zumindest immer und
immer wieder dort diese schutzräume
aufsuchen muss peter und paul worauf
stellen sich die menschen tatsächlich
ein und was ist so ein moment wo man
sagt okay jetzt geben wir hoch jetzt
brauchen wir erstmal keinen schutz das
ist ja auch eine sehr ruhige
entscheidung ja das sind immer so
intervalle also die sirenen kommen und
mein kollege der kameramann trubelig
falls ja heute gerade kurz raus fahren
ein paar bilder machen in dem moment wo
eben die bilder wo er die kamera
eingepackt hat kamen auf einmal sofort
schon wieder der alarm die sirene das
heißt dann geht man raus aus dem auto
muss dann die dass schnell in den
punkten weil wir wissen wir im endeffekt
etwas bombardiert wird und wenn man hier
langfeld man weiß ja auch nicht welches
strategische
ist man fährt irgendwo vor bei der bombe
hoch und das war es dann also man sollte
schon auf diese sie reden hören und die
sind natürlich heute in einem sehr
relativ montag immerhin der hat man
zugehört und es ist eigentlich immer
wieder angerannt runter in den bogen
kadern wartet man man hat kontakt auch
oben
und dann sagen die op die luft ist rein
mehr oder weniger und dann kann man
wieder nach oben gehen kann vielleicht
mit seiner arbeit machen aber so das ist
im moment der tagesablauf und wie du
schon richtig sagt es kann wir wissen
nicht wie lange das dauert das kann auch
tage dauern dass sich diese situation so
zu uns einstellen jetzt kam eben gerade
die eilmeldungen rein dass die eu das
vermögen von vladimir putin und auch von
außenminister lavrov einfrieren will wie
schätzt ihr dass ein wie schmerzhaft ist
das für putin oder kommt das gar in
dieser zeit wo er jetzt gerade
vorsichtig angedeutet hat über russische
medien dass sie zu gesprächen
friedensgesprächen mit der ukraine
bereit ist zu einem vielleicht eher
ungünstigen zeitpunkt nein das kommt
überhaupt nicht zu einem ungünstigen
zeitpunkt wir müssen endlich anfangen
eine realistische sicht auf vladimir
putin zu haben nicht aber auch all
diejenigen die waren in den vergangenen
wochen monaten jahren und immer gesagt
haben wir müssen reden dürfe nicht
provoziert und gesagt haben der wird
schon nicht hier angreifen der
wirtschaft nicht die gesamte ukraine
angreifen die sagen ja selbst einmal das
plazet jetzt er wurde von putin oder
fühlt sich getäuscht von daher erst dann
wenn es wirklich eine möglichkeit die
das hier zu beenden kann man darüber
sprechen und das unabhängig davon über
was man jetzt verhandelt an der tatsache
dass wladimir putin geordnet hat eine
invasion gegen die ukraine das ist eine
tatsache und es sind ja bereits mehrere
städte und seine armee erobert worden
von daher reagiert die westliche welt
völlig zu recht auf diese tatsachen
danke paul ronzheimer danke peter hell
dort in diesen schutzraum in kiew danke
für eure schilderung von dort